[Music]
some of the changes are going on with
HMOs and the legislation in article 4
I'm so happy let me explain this do you
guys know what article 4 is article 4
all right first let me explain something
the deals that we've been finding up
until this point today have been
profiting us in our back pocket I ran
about 300 pound a month three maybe four
hundred pound a month how many of those
do you need to be financially free ten
how would you like it if you can retire
on just two or three deals the deals
that we're buying right now the deals
that my students are by mine now you got
to be able to do the foundational stuff
I could go on to some complicated stuff
with you guys
bells and whistles and and you drop the
balls but now you've got the foundation
in a property investor I'm working out
the ROI I want to talk to you guys about
how you can absolutely kill it with HMOs
because this is what makes me most of my
cash flow hmmm properties at the
definition of a HMO is super simple
people overcomplicate this it's a house
of multiple occupancy it's a house where
you rent it out on a room-by-room basis
how much rent do these houses that we've
been looking at how much rent do they
give us in a month four or five hundred
guess how much rent we'll get on an
average room for about four or five
hundred per room which means that we've
got four or five hundred forty four four
eight twelve sixteen sixteen hundred
pounds rent per month for one house when
you buy houses like this what happens is
you don't need that many
all right okay okay yes or no you need
like two or three maybe four if you're
extra greedy so how do you find secure
and buy houses like this well first let
me just talk about legislation there's
two types of legislation when it comes
to HMOs how many types please one is
called planning one is called a
licensing if the HMO has got five or
more bedrooms you need a license getting
a license is it really hard or is it all
right it's easy as long as the house is
fit for purpose that's it if it's four
bedrooms or three or four yeah you don't
need a license so you just buy it and
rent it out by the rooms I'm not saying
that you shouldn't put fire doors in and
make it safe of course but you don't
need a license planning there's two
reasons why you need planning one reason
is because there are seven or more
bedrooms and then you need planning the
second reason is because it's an article
for area then you need planning planning
is planning really harder is it okay
it's hard so what I would what I would
suggest that you guys do is you guys buy
HMOs you rent out on a room-by-room
basis but when it comes to the rules you
just make sure that there's not more
than seven bedrooms and article four
we'll get to this is the country right
it's not sure about this but let's just
say this is England
back in the day few years ago this is
article 4
this is article for this is article 4
and this is article 4 and there's a tiny
bit of article 4 yeah article 4 are
zones by the council and the council say
in this area you can no longer buy a
house and rent the rooms out because
that's changing its use so if you want
to buy a house in these areas and you
want to change the use you got to get
planning permission which they probably
won't give you and it's a nightmare
so in these areas what happened was
people went oh my gosh you can't do you
hate your Mo's so oh man I can't do HMOs
here anymore so they all start investing
in HMOs here and then they bring article
4 here people what's going on right now
it's like this article for article for
article 4 there's there's only like this
much of non article 4 areas now they're
good news or bad news
it sounds like bad news everyone's
saying that sucks
they tell you why
let me tell you I disagree now October
this year they are bringing article 4
in to Doncaster now when they bring
article 4 in to Doncaster do I then need
to get planning when they bring article
4 in to Doncaster it's gonna mean that
anyone new buying houses and donk a
stick they can't do it anymore
me with my property that I have bought
just before article 4 comes in I will
have something called the grand father
rights was it called bliss grandfather
rights which means that I will have
automatic planning permission on that
property which means what's going to
happen to my competition no 0 because
they'll still be properties that were
bought beforehand but no more newbies
can come onto my patch what's going to
happen to these the demand for rooms
again they go up so I'm gonna rent it
about three to five a room this price
don't mind it was bought like at 95 in
2016 I just bought it for 94 it's now
since had a refurb when that becomes
article for the price is gonna go up the
rents are going to go up I bought a
house for 135 in Wolverhampton in 2017
August 1 3 5 the following month
they brought article 4 in
two months later I was offered someone
offered to buy a cash for one-nine-five
this is how you get maximum cash flow
maximum capital appreciation